lockdowns have left millions of us
shaggy-haired for these New Zealanders
it's been a bad hair day that's lasted
seven weeks so when the country's
lockdown ended at midnight they were
already queueing for a cut as the clock
struck twelve these Samsung's could lose
their locks and New Zealand could enter
the next stage of its coronavirus
response we've got seven barbers in
Birkenhead
13 hairdressing salons she got the boys
organized in three hours to open at one
minute past 12:00 so we're gonna be
looking as sharp as Elvis when we chin
up at work tomorrow
other businesses including cafes have
also reopened their doors New Zealand's
lockdown came quickly when the country
had only a hundred and two cases and no
deaths it has been especially strict and
especially effective the country has
recorded just 21 covert 19 deaths and
has stopped the community spread of the
virus effectively eliminating it it's
magic and great to just reconnect and
actually be in a different I earn meant
there's been no focus - I think good
view lovely day
so yeah I just have someone else make a
coffee for a changes it's fantastic that
success means relieved looking parents
could take their children back to school
and weddings could go ahead this couple
a British bride and a Swiss groom were
caught in lockdown on holiday they
decided to change their plans and marry
here instead others like this politician
celebrated the end of lockdown in their
own way a bid to drive up tourism and a
bungee jump is about as far as you can
get from quarantine at home this is not
a return to normal though or even the
new normal normal isn't coming back
measures like social distancing are
being enforced and the country could
reintroduce lock downs in the future if
kovat numbers rise but easing the
lockdown letting people back into shops
means the economy can get firing again
and to that end the government announced
a record 50 billion New Zealand Dollars
budget the equivalent of 25 billion
pounds we had been a government that
with the support and efforts of New
Zealanders took us through an enormous
health challenge and we will take the
same approach to the recovery of our
economy the weariness remains but this
is the most important thing right now
people who are apart for so long or
again together
Tom Tesco news
[Applause]